while we have you here you have you have
some inside information on our boy
Michael B Jordan and Laura
okay
okay my bad what's inside he's missing a
letter from yeah
apostrophe r-e-a-l oh
yeah
okay I don't think there's no inside
information I mean like you want to know
the conversation I had with L'Oreal yeah
yes please
um based about what specifically though
okay so basically just the setup is
she's interviewing Mike Michael Jordan
on the red carpet that's right right and
Michael B Jordan is looking a little
salty yeah yeah right he's confronting a
bully he is
you see it look at it look at him
all right here we go okay now we know
each other we go way back all the way to
Chad science and Newark okay
no you did not hear me say cry I said we
used to make fun of the name yeah but
yeah he is obviously killing how many
head nods yo
said at the end okay what did she say
then at the end she said he's not corny
anymore yeah so from a from a
personality perspective well thanks for
pointing that out
l'oreality perspective you can't do that
after saying you didn't call him corny
yeah you can't come back at the end and
be like he's not corny anymore because
you already said you didn't call him
corny yeah oh so you're saying that you
did call him but she didn't though
because like I did not say that I did
not say that he really did it it was it
was uh Dominique the Divo they were
doing a podcast together Dominique the
diva called him corny do you want to
hear this you know what I really think
things out inside I think that Michael B
Jordan is just like a nice corny guy you
know it's so crazy I went to school with
Michael B so yeah she calls him or that
one girl calls him a nice corny guy and
then she says I went to school with him
that was Dominique the Divas team also
said like I'm we used to make fun of him
what you gonna do with them stupid
little as I told L'Oreal the thing that
she has to eat is like that's the that's
the problem right what you gonna do with
them stupid little headshots become one
of the biggest superstars in the world
yeah so once that happens you just gotta
take the L on that yeah but why is he
still tight so everybody's tight over
people that got if you got teased in
high school about something and you
became you became that something you
want to tell everybody one thing let me
and look I want to know your thoughts
I'm not arguing with you he was in The
Wire probably shooting by the time he
was 14. so he was already winning so he
already I'm on a I'm on an HBO show even
if it wasn't popping for a few years
what am I gonna do with little stupid
headshots I'm on an HBO show I real HBO
don't pay for [__] if he's still living
in Newark
are you a child yeah
defined as corny nowadays
you know what I'm saying like why was
Michael B Jordan corny because he had a
dream and some Ambitions I think we're
gonna Embrace corny like we embraced
watched you know how older people are
like I'm watching I'm okay absolutely we
used to call Drake Courtney back in the
day and now everybody is on his dick
I'm consistently still calling him corny
honest I don't mean super soft and all
that stuff and then you got a couple
bottles and then all of a sudden these
eyes
loved how he handled that situation with
Meek Mill so that was the turning point
for me being like yeah oh man I like the
way this guy gets down I thought Nick
was going to be the ruthless
[__] to come out with two
records back to back yeah if that's the
best way to answer somebody you say I'm
a ghost writer all right we'll get these
bars you know what I'm saying on behalf
of corny people we tend to hold on to
[__] and just Drake had that building
for years but what's not Coronado like
all this [__] that we consider cool nine
times out of ten was just some criminal
[__] yeah you know what I mean like all
the [__] yeah all the
[__] who considered cool in
school ended up probably in prison
because that's cool yeah you know what I
mean being bad is cool
isn't cool being good is corny but being
corny makes you a millionaire I like
listen I would rather my daughters date
the corny guy you know what I mean okay
so that's what you're saying you're
saying that the the description was
accurate he was corny and his cornness
led him to be a Megasaur super
successful he just hasn't accepted that
his corn is is what makes him great yeah
all the cool kids they were skipping
class exactly
exactly they're gangsters right now so
but it what I'm saying is I'm looking at
this and I'm seeing a guy who's like
really upset like it really bothered him
did this girl called him corny yeah like
the head not like a million like he was
waiting for that moment he could have
walked right by her I like how Dominique
the D would know son if you don't hold
the ground to be honest only with people
that are higher than me
does that pass you it all just melts
away there were people that were like
dicks to me when I started comedy I told
you I had a list yes I remember get the
list for them and everyone I passed it
evap you it evaporated my anger
evaporated for them and I see them and I
dab it off like you've gone back at them
yeah that are smaller than you yeah oh
yeah that's true yeah rarely though
imagine
what that means that means those jokes
if you still remember that [__] at 33 yo
those jokes that you was getting hit
with in high school I thought you said
this on the podcast before but I think I
said I don't know if I said it but like
I've this made me realize I definitely
talked some [__] about Michael B Jordan
and forgot I did really yeah because I
met him the other day I was having
dinner I was having dinner I was having
dinner with uh
Jordan came over to the table and he
went he shook and I had my hand out for
like a good two minutes he must have
shook everybody else's hand with the
[__] table before he finally came out
around to me and I was like is he doing
this on purpose like what the [__] is
going on and I saw the L'Oreal [__] and
I was like oh no I've said something
that's why you don't like this [__]
if it makes you feel better the second
he gets bigger than Michael B Jordan he
freaking Michael Jordan did you see how
Dominique the D would double down though
oh yeah she was posted on her Instagram
yeah she posted on her Instagram story
any black man that dates white women is
corny the woman that called him Pony
originally yeah so she doubled down
that's actually a good ass point like I
don't even wanna I don't even want to
tease Michael about that no more about
what Danny white women yeah why because
I be joking but now it seems like that's
really good I'll be joking you know you
got some um
I I believe love is love you know what
I'm saying but he was just dating what
be honest you know what I mean I don't
know I believe black men should be with
black women that's a fact I am I'm with
that you know and when they're not
when they're not they're not you know
what I mean
[Music]
like what do you mean by it
I don't think they might be joining but
if you're one of these pro-black people
like you wake up in the morning and you
can't wait to you know to be black to be
black like you getting that everybody
attacking racism but then you go on the
street
s yeah there's a white significant other
that's like come on bro that's my least
favorite come on sisters oh you know
what I mean yeah that's what that's what
I'm that's what about what about black
women today white dude same thing but
especially if you're super pro black
yeah you're super pro black about it
it's like you know why what about the
black love is Revolution what about AOC
what about AOC what is it what is she
afro she's down for Latino what about
her she's dating the least black person
possible really in a ginger yeah yeah no
yeah
really yes you know why for some reason
why
I don't know
I don't bother politicians like
transcend race alone Viana Presley was
doing that I might be like ah come on
who's Ayanna Presley another member of
the squad oh [__] yeah but she got a
brother she got a brother but I met her
husband yeah that don't bother me seeing
AOC with a ginger you know why I think
they're so militant as they're insecure
about the fact that they're attracted to
this other race and they might get
mocked more men overcome
more man but they don't know how to say
about dating them come on man
that's too much come on man but I think
I'm thinking a lot of people don't want
to talk about is like there's a lot of
black dudes that would like to date
black women but black women aren't into
them and so they're relegated to dating
outside their race and then they get
[__] on for dating outside there I think
that's a misconception I think that you
know there's plenty of black women that
want to date black men but everybody has
all of these like you know standards and
these these these rules of engagement
that don't even necessarily make sense
like it's all these things that keep us
from actually you know bonding with each
other like what you just said is one of
those things like you said uh black
women are what do you say black women
want to date black men but they don't
what do you say what reasons
but black women are like nah these dudes
this dude's corny I don't want to date
him and then a white girl might so he's
like okay that couldn't be Michael B
Jordan go where you're celebrating now
were you celebrate two black women
calling Michael Jordan Courtney but
that's them
think about that and by the way context
matters right because L'Oreal's talking
about high school that's a difference of
years man those all of us were corny in
high school in some way shape before
they might have thought he was Corner
because he's in he lives in Newark and
then he's acting as a drug dealer and
it's like bro there's plenty of real
drug dealers here
now Dominique Dominique the diva her
point of saying you know any black man
that dates white women is corny that's
talking about Michael now L'Oreal is
talking about Michael from back then I
think that's the difference that that
that that that that needs contact I
guess what I'm saying to defend him is
don't you think informative years if the
black women you grew up with are calling
you corny it could push you to be an
attracted because now you're on set
there's white girls I've already gone
meetings in L.A
think about where you at you're in
Newark
you know what I'm saying once you get
out of news you'll probably find some
black women that appreciate the corny
and new you don't want no corny
especially back then yeah you get two
kills exactly you want what you think is
cool back then it probably was the drug
dealer the shooter the gang member back
back then you know yeah yeah yeah I
think he comes across as a hero for like
a lot of people after this like all the
characters like all the young kids now
they're getting bullied in high school
and girls are like the hand cell types
they're looking at this and they're like
that's and the dreamers yeah yeah the
dreamers everybody wants them I think
you look a little too angry about it
who cares I told L'Oreal you're still
bothering him and the crazy part is
L'Oreal is known as the bully right yeah
right yeah
if she called him corny right there to
his face he would have punched her in
the mouth no I think he would have well
that would work for her
that's the only way to win in that
situation he would have to jump out the
window and hit her now any other any
other way this played out she's the
bully in this situation yeah so in order
to be a victim
he would have to do something like that
doesn't know and I told her that there's
no way for you to win this like this is
every dreamer's dream right like like
the person who used to [__] on you told
you that you wasn't gonna be [__]
laughed at you walking around with your
headshots now on the precipice of me
having my first movie that I directed
and starring yeah I get to see you on
the red carpet of my [__] yeah and check
you
can you tell me enough you're not saying
nothing come on man you'd be funny oh
man come on man you eyeing that
[__] that's why I don't
understand LeBron James
LeBron James has never spiked the ball
on Skip Bayless show ever when would he
be able to what you mean the time the
times he's won championships the time
he's broke the scoring record he's still
considered you know the number two
greatest player of all time like Now's
the Time to pop yourself
crazy it drives him [__] crazy the
fact that LeBron won't even mention that
even she would do but it feels good even
when but that shows the emotional
security of LeBron like it's really
impressive LeBron doesn't do that what
I'm saying is I'd like to see Michael
beaters
exactly yo all I'm saying wait LeBron
doesn't have it bro we saw bro I'm about
to fight somebody because they were
teasing him about his headline as he was
walking off the court that [__]
was right there bro you got your wife
you got your side chick like there's a
lot of people there that could be
embarrassed in front of you yeah it
might be the hairline he's insecure
about his hairline he's not insecure
about his basketball ability yeah
that's a great Point yeah you're tapping
into the thing that he's insecure about
that's where you're going to react and
also LeBron's patient I guarantee when
he goes to retire he'll say assumption
because think about it when he uh broke
the scoring record he dropped the F-bomb
live while they were talking about I
mean no what's that he kind of matters
he calls Skip and F on dude
but he said [__] while he was like
come on that's not the boss
he's been so clean all these years
you know what the news
when we're describing your outfit
is it kind of weird that he still did
the interview like if he just gunked on
or walked off I thought it was funny or
whatever but the fact that he still
stayed and answered like four questions
legitimately after that I respect that
he's a professional yeah he want you won
already yeah you won already and that's
why at the end L'Oreal should not have
said but you're not corny anymore like
don't even acknowledge you just you said
you didn't call him cornies don't even
go back to that making it seem like you
did you know what I mean that's what
just seems a little strange yeah that's
all I think she just panicked you think
so she got confronted by this guy she's
talking about on a podcast you get
confronted all of a sudden on the red
carpet interviewing him at his event you
lost you've got to be prepared for that
moment like if I'm like I think she knew
okay I'm going to I'm doing the red
carpet at Creed Three Michael B Jordan's
probably gonna walk this red carpet